house lawmakers about their
handling of the 2nd and 3rd
largest bank collapses in U. S
history yesterday before the
senate banking committee. They
admitted that banks deserve more
scrutiny and suggested that the
executives of the failed banks
might face punishment. This is a
textbook case of bank
mismanagement. Their risk the
bank face interest rate risk and
liquidity risk our bread and
butter banking issues. The firm
was quite aware of those issues.
They were quite vulnerable to
risk to shocks and they didn't
take the actions necessary.
Joining us now for his
perspective on that hearing,
Kevin o'leary, judge on shark
tank and chairman of o'leary
ventures. Lot of buck passing
that went on during that hearing
yesterday, don't you think?
Don't you say what? You really
feel this time, okay? Kevin
never does. You know? Um were
there idiot bankers? Yes where
they incompetent? Yes when you
have top lawmakers calling you
the worst of the worst of the
worst. It just doesn't get any
worse, and it can't get any
worse for those people. But
they're not even the mandate or
story anymore. It doesn't
matter. The question becomes,
what do we do about regional
banking in this country going
forward, and that's really
what's the debate here? Because
you know if you're a consumer,
and you're sitting with more
than 250,000 in a small bank in
some states somewhere, and
you're watching this play out in
Washington, with all the
grandstanding of hearings what
do you do? Do you feel better or
worse? I say you feel worse. I
say this is the beginning of the
demise of small banks for sure.
And that we're going to end up
with an oligopoly of very large
institutions with an imputed
concept that they're backed by
the federal government. Not
guaranteed imputed. You're not
advocating for that. You're
saying that's just what's going
to happen. I'm not advocating
for it. I have come to the
conclusion as many others have
that are discussing this that I
do not want to pay. For every
idiot bankers. Mistake it's not
on me as a taxpayer, and there
are many idiot bankers. I know
it's harsh words, but let's put
it the way it is. These people
were incompetent, and that's
what happened now. Why do I own
that problem, particularly if I
don't live in California? I
don't care what they do in
California, and that's why I'm
saying okay, now that we're
learning this what are we going
to do about it? What's the new
plan? Ask one thing, because
you're what you're saying. It
goes with this. You're saying
that every taxpayer should be
asking one question right now.
And what is that? What is that
question? Do I personally want
to guarantee every tiny bank in
America? That's the only
question we need to answer. Is
it? Yes or no? It was it not
because you heard yelling
backpedal from that when she
proposed the idea that there's
going to be a guarantee, no
matter what the amount is in
every single account in America.
And the backlash that came
through from that was a heavy
wave. And she said, well, okay,
maybe not. Now we have the same
question back because what
you're saying is different than
the white house is saying which
they're saying. Taxpayers aren't
on the hook for this because
it's being paid through the
fees. But you're arguing
indirectly. It is them on the
hook for this. The question,
though I think coming out of
this is then what are the
solutions? Because you heard a
lot of the grilling that
happened yesterday. You didn't
hear a lot of answers about how
to resolve these issues. All
right, let me suggest a
solution. Okay okay, state and
remember why we had regional
banks in the first place because
you as a state said, we're
different than anywhere else in
America. Our economy is based on
technology service to
communities service to
community. A kumbaya thing? No.
Your bank or mortgages for your
commercial real estate. Maybe
your home. And it's just a
wonderful feeling that you used
to drive your bicycle to the
regional bank and go in and take
out $10. Okay that's what the
emotional tied to a regional
bank is. Is any of that reality
today? No it's all done online,
so we don't even need that
building. However if you really
want to have a regional bank,
and you feel as a governor or
senator of your state then you
should own the risk. You should
tell the people in your voting
constituency that can't you have
a mid sized bank? Why can't you
have a community bank and not
you? The individual be the
person who's on the hook for the
bank's actions because you don't
need it. That's my whole point.
You get a credit card from a
regional bank. No you go online.
You put your people have credit
cards and regional banks. Do you
need that? You don't a lot of
people do that. Okay we talked
about this. Last time you were
here. They were instrumental
kumbaya. Why we should keep this
open. But you asked me the tough
questions. Well, would you
personally guarantee the bank in
New Jersey or New York? Would
you personally go on the hook?
Because you want to have a
regional bank in these states?
Yes or no banks are important. I
think they served communities.
I'm telling you, I'm from a
small town in Alabama. When the
P P P loans were going out.
People don't get online and go
to JPMorgan. If they own a small
mom and pop business or go to a
bank, then today. It's different
because you basically do
everything online. So what I'm
arguing is I just want you to
take ownership of your come by a
saying, if you really want to
keep a regional bank open a
sentimental person. I'm saying
that I think they are actually
instrumental that they're
helpful to midsized communities
after we had during the last
time I heard from people who
would you believe that? Then you
eat it. I'm I'm Mr taxpayer in
any state represent all the rest
of us who don't agree with you
and are saying you want that you
eat it, and so it is there no
medium you know, if you're
saying I understand what you're
saying, make money or you lose
money. It's binary. It's black
or white. Either you are going
to back up that bank because you
think it has merit. Or you
don't. I'm telling you if you
take a vote in America today,
and you go to every single
constituency in every city and
say, do you want to own the
problems of a New York bank or
California bank or Massachusetts
bank or Minnesota bank? They'll
put up their heads. So what does
it have to do with me? I go
online and get my credit card
for somewhere else. This is the
debate. We're having an
American. What we're going to
see today on the hill is just
more bank bashing, and by the
way, I listened to the testimony
as an investor. I am never going
to buy a bank stock. It's over.
All right, let me look. Kind of
like going to my local my
hometown lived. No no, no, no,
no, I kind of like the idea. But
I do understand what you're
saying. It's not necessary. It's
not needed anymore. It's not
Mayberry usa anymore. Even
though you know we have that.
You know, we've kind of want
that nostalgia, right? We want
to go to our local. You want it
done, but you don't want to pay
for it. I'm just saying you in
the universal since I'm not
saying me specifically, but do I
like going into the bank and
people saying, hey, Mr lemon,
how are you? Good to see you. I
like that. But I understand what
you're saying. Not necessary
anymore. We don't necessarily
need to get your time in America
to ask Americans do they want to
pay for these things? Got you
all right. I understand that,
but just quickly. Do you think
that these execs should have
their bonuses clawed back? It's
gonna get way worse than that
for them. They're going to be
negligent in the it's never good
when you're sitting at home on
your sofa and you're watching.
Congress testify with your name
that you're a bad manager. I
guarantee you they're all having
bad hair days and unless $3
million that they got two weeks,
the CEO sold his stock. He's
already spent that in legal fees
, they may want to claw it back.
But he is up to his. You know